[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be discussing the possible ways in
which the tournament of power could end
including the top 5 possible endings
that I personally think are the most
likely so this will not be anything like
fused samus who suddenly returns and
interrupts the tournament these are all
realistic and plausible ways that the
tournament could end I know that there
are a lot of YouTube videos out there
already talking about this topic how the
tournament of power will end but many of
those videos are from a few months ago
and a lot has happened since then and we
also received a ton of new information
in the last few days alone so I think
this video will be very different than
some of those older ones and of course
we just learned that the new Dragon Ball
movie that is coming out in December of
2018 will be the next part in the story
of Dragon Ball super and this is massive
news it means that this movie will not
be just any Dragon Ball movie it'll be a
Dragon Ball super movie a continuation
of the Dragon Ball super story and of
course this makes the ending of the
tournament of power even more important
just so you know here at anime up roar
we will continue to make Dragon Ball
content even after episode 131 so if you
enjoyed the Dragon Ball super videos on
this channel be sure to leave a like and
if you are new don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification valve and a
quick note in this video we will be
addressing the spoilers that have been
recently revealed for episode 1 3 1 and
these spoilers definitely give us some
clues about the ending of the tournament
however we don't know the actual ending
yet so this is still just speculation
based on some general information that
we have so far as we now know episode
131 of Dragon Ball super is called a
miraculous conclusion farewell Goku
until the day we meet again and by the
way the credit for revealing the
spoilers goes to geek Tom 101 and to
Herms I will link to geek Tom's video
about episode 131 spoilers in the
description and I will link to Herms his
Twitter as well I know that a lot of
people have been talking about this
topic but geekdom is the
that I personally watched for this type
of info now from these spoilers we
learned that at one point in episode 131
Goku will fall from the arena and it
will appear that universe 7 has been
defeated but then Goku and Gian are
staring at the Omni Kings the two xenos
as if the match isn't over yet at that
moment a death beam suddenly hits jiren
in the back and an injured Frieza who of
course still hasn't been eliminated
appears once again as soon as this
information came out a lot of fans
started complaining because they are
assuming that all of this means that
Goku loses two jiren but it is not that
simple
as you will see in this video keeping
that in mind here is my list for the top
five possible endings for the tournament
of power at number five Goku wins
outright the most popular theory about
how the tournament will end at least
until we got the spoilers about Goku
apparently falling from the arena was
that Goku will simply defeat jiren and
with Goku recently mastering ultra
instinct and increasing his power and
speed many times over it wouldn't be too
surprising to see Goku beat jiren after
all Dragon Ball is the story of Goku's
life and how he goes from being just a
child to one of the strongest fighters
and the multiverse even though the
spoiler says that Goku falls from the
arena there could still be a twist in
store for us something like Goku landing
on a stray piece of rock that used to be
part of the arena and managing to stay
in that way similar twists have happened
in the past and the spoiler does say
that Goku and jeer and are staring in
the Omni Kings as if the match is not
over the other reason why this ending is
plausible is the fact that the winner of
the tournament gets to make a wish with
the super Dragon Balls I personally
believe that the universes that have
been erased during the tournament will
definitely be brought back and the
easiest way of doing this is with the
super Dragon Balls after all this is
Dragon Ball and I simply cannot imagine
that the show will end with seven entire
universes being erased
especially universe 6 since we've come
to know some of these characters really
well including of course hit Cabo kale
cauliflower and Champa the Dragon Ball
franchise is famous for wishing people
back to life including huge groups of
people at the same time such as wishing
back
everyone who was killed by Frieza and
his henchmen on Namek or everyone who
was killed by selling the androids on
earth so I just can't see them ending
the story without bringing back the
universes since out of the three
remaining fighters in the tournament
goku is the most likely to use his wish
for something like this
there is a strong logical argument to be
made for goku winning the tournament
number 4
kiran will win the tournament jiren has
been built up for a long time as an
incredibly powerful fighter immortal
stronger even than the gods of
destruction so it would definitely make
sense story wise if jiren somehow manage
to defeat goku and win the tournament
goku fans would be upset for sure but it
wouldn't be too shocking to see Jun win
since Giants power was far ahead of
Goku's before the tournament began now
we know that Gian has his own wish that
he desperately wants granted and if it
turns out that Juran's wish is to bring
back his parents from the dead or
something like that then this would mean
that the erased universes would stay
erased as I said I just don't see this
happening so the only way I see Gian
winning and being the one to make the
wish is if he has some sort of moment of
self-reflection where he realizes that
the well-being of entire universes is
more important than his personal wish
and he then uses his wish to bring back
the universes instead of bringing back
his parents or anything along those
lines we do know that girion cares a lot
about justice
so it isn't unthinkable for him to
potentially come to the realization and
wishing back the erased universes is the
right thing to do so I do think that
something like this could potentially
happen at number 3 Frieza wins the
tournament of power even though all the
action in the tournament right now seems
to be focused on the showdown between
Goku and G R and we can't forget that
Frieza is still in the tournament he
hasn't been eliminated from the episode
131 spoilers we know that Frieza will
make a move and in fact it is suggested
that Frieza will attack Jaron from
behind so is it possible that Frieza
could somehow win despite the fact that
his power seems to be nowhere near Goku
or jiren I've heard some theories out
there that Frieza has a hidden power
that no one knows about and that he will
use it at the right moment to win but I
really doubt it because if Frieza had a
hidden power he definitely would have
used
when he was being humiliated in the
battle against topo I mean let's just
look at freezes character his
personality he is just way too proud to
take that type of abuse from someone he
considers inferior unless he really had
no other choice the only way that I see
Frieza winning is one of two options
option one is that Goku and G R and will
tire each other out to such an extent
that Frieza will be able to take Jun on
with a surprise attack and Gian will be
too exhausted to fight back option two
is that while Goku and Gian are fighting
maybe on the edge of the fighting arena
Frieza will launch a surprise attack
that knocks cheerin out of the arena
before he has time to react so for
example gern and Goku are fighting on a
piece of rock and Frieza destroys that
piece of rock and both of them fall off
that would be the best-case scenario for
Frieza since he would then get to make
the wish but if Frieza gets to make the
wish he probably won't wish to revive
the other universes instead he will most
likely wish for himself to become as
powerful as the Omni King or something
along those lines and again I just don't
see Dragon Ball super ending with those
universes staying erased unless we get a
hint that in the sequel in this movie
that's coming out in December the
universe's are going to be brought back
number 2 the time will run out Dragon
Ball super has spent a lot of time
making sure that we understand that
there is a strict time limit for the
tournament and each episode we are
reminded that time is running out
the time is clearly important for the
writers of the stories so what if
instead of ending in a decisive victory
the tournament of power ends because the
time runs out for example Goku and G R
and continue to fight but neither of
them can get the upper hand before the
time runs out so the tournament is
stopped and that is why the spoiler for
episode one thirty one talks about Goku
and jiren staring up at the Omni King as
of the match isn't over if the time runs
out before they finish their fight it
makes sense for them to both look up at
the Z nose as if to ask what happens now
do we finish the fight do we stop what
do we do if the time runs out while Goku
and Gian are fighting but Frieza is
still in the arena then according to the
rules universe 7 will be the winner I am
sure that if the tournament ends this
way a lot of people will complain that
the ending was anticlimactic because
they wanted to see someone win in an
epic way but this type of ending would
make sense for a number of reasons as I
said earlier jiren has been built up as
this incredibly powerful fighter for a
long time so it makes sense that Goku
would struggle to just defeat him
outright since we have to remember that
the tournament started only 48 minutes
ago and Goku has already gotten so much
stronger in that short period of time if
Goku outright defeats Jaron after coming
into the tournament so much weaker than
him a ton of people will complain that
this is unrealistic and just plot armor
but if in the end Goku can hold his own
against jiren but can't beat him
decisively before the time runs out then
the whole thing seems a bit more
realistic
if this happens jiren technically
remains undefeated but Goku still gets
to wish back all the erased universes
although in that case it would be
interesting to see Goku and Frieza argue
about which of them gets to make the
wish and number one the tournament ends
in a tie finally the one option that I
am leaning towards right now is that the
tournament will end in a tie how is this
possible well let's assume that the
episode won 3-1 spoiler is true when
Goku really does fall out of the arena
and is eliminated at this point Goku
looks up at the Omni Kings from the
stands and jiren looks up at them from
the arena but the tournament isn't over
because Frieza is still there Frieza
attacks jiren from behind but even
though Frieza
isn't strong enough to overcome cheer
and in his weakened state after the epic
battle with Goku jiren is unable to
knock Frieza out of the tournament
before the time runs out this means that
in the end there is one member of
universe 11 still in the tournament
cheerin and one member of universe 7
Frieza and the tournament ends in a tie
to me this might be the most interesting
way to end the tournament because we
have no idea what happens next who gets
to make the wish if there is no clear
winner is there going to be a rematch of
some kind or as thus it at I would leave
so many unanswered questions that it
would lend itself perfectly to setting
up some kind of sequel I've always
thought that an open-ended ending to
Dragon Ball super would mean that a
sequel is more likely than if we got an
ending that wraps everything up
perfectly so I could definitely live
with the tournament of power ending in a
tie but let me know what you guys think
which ending is most likely and would
you be ok if the tournament ended as a
tie or as a result of the time running
out or do you want to see someone emerge
as the decisive winner let me know down
in the comments if you enjoy the Dragon
Ball super
on this channel I want to see more be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you have some draggable super
fan art that you want to share with us
and have it potentially featured in a
future video be sure to follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
and if you want to discuss anime
theories recommendations and a lot more
you can join our discord server link in
the description as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]